[Music]
good evening everybody this is chess
openings explained and i'm your
instructor
nick risco i'm one of the private lesson
instructors here at the st
louis chess club and tonight we're going
to be going over the rasalimo attack
in the sicilian so i want to give a
shout out to fred in the chat
asking us to cover the sicilian this is
one of the lines in the sicilian
and yeah if you guys have any questions
just ask right away in the chat if it's
about a specific move or specific line
please put a move number
that way i can uh you know better
understand what your question is in
reference to
so for those of you who don't know we're
going to go to the chessboard here
the sicilian starts off with e4 and c5
and we actually covered
a branch in the sicilian last week the
pin variation
the idea with e4 c5 is that white
is going to get some rapid development
and black is going to be prepared to
trade off the c
pawn in the center for better center
control
now here white probably their best shot
for winning chances is going to be
knight to f3
and black can go knight to c6
and here it can lead to uh
probably the freshnikov positions where
white will play d4 captures captures
knight f6 knight c3 and e5
and then knight d to b5 and these
positions can be
very sharp and can get very confusing if
you haven't done your homework
and some players may think this is too
sharp and want to avoid this
so instead of playing d4
what we're going to be covering tonight
is probably the best theoretical
sideline
to d4 bishop to b5
this is the nizet minov rasalimo attack
and like i said it's been claimed to be
the best theoretical alternative to the
open variations
and is pretty logical as well you
develop the light square bishop
so white is ready to castle on the king
side
and your your pawn structure you haven't
committed to anything yet so it's very
flexible
and the point of aiming at c6
is that you're putting your bishop there
in such a way that you can inflict
double pawns on
black i want to mention very quickly
that uh pawn to d6 and then bishop to b5
check is not the rossolimo variation
i just want to clarify this one this is
the moscow variation
which there can be some transpositions
if black goes d6 on move three
but this is not going to be our main
focus tonight
so again knight to c6 and then bishop to
b5
this is the proper rossolimo attack
and here there are quite a few ways that
black can respond actually
and i'm still wondering if we're going
to get through all of them tonight
but we'll start with some of the lesser
known moves starting off with one that
has shown up recently not in a game
but actually in the show the queen's
gambit where
the first time beth harmon is playing
borgov
borgov plays the russolimo and then beth
goes
queen to b6 so i figured i should at
least cover this move
since it made that appearance and i
really couldn't find like
some refutation for queen b6 being a bad
move though it isn't to the most played
but it will show some ideas that white
has
first we'll look at what happens if
white captures on c6
anyway this is going to be one of the
main ideas and here
instead of taking back with a pawn
which is probably why black plays queen
b6 in the first place is they recapture
with the queen and they avoid the
doubled pawns but they're losing some
time by moving the queen more than once
in the opening
and now white can castle and black
should probably play d6 here they can
try taking on e4
but after rook to e1 queen to c6 and
pawn to d4
i guess pawn to d6 trying to open lines
up for your pieces
and pawn to c4 white stands a bit better
here because
of the center it's not like black has
damaged it at all
and you have the knight developed the
rook is in the center
your queen is ready to come up if needed
your bishop's ready to come out and
black still has quite a bit of work
especially on this dark square bishop so
they should try and go d6 earlier
rather than going for the center pawn
and now pawn to d4
they can trade in the center and now
queen takes e4 because
you're putting pressure on this knight
if white isn't careful you know they
can't just move the queen to f3
trying to trade queens queen takes d4
so knight c3 hits the queen queen to g4
and avoiding the queen trade go queen to
d3
and white stands better here they're
down a pawn but they have
all the development with the knights
that should compensate for it
the other option white has instead of
taking on c6
is you can play knight to c3 just
developing the bishop
and this move is a bit more popular and
i think i like it more because
it's developing another piece and
the e4 pawn doesn't hang in some of
these lines
black will continue with e6 rather than
d6 here
and the point of e6 is you're trying to
prepare d5
white will castle uh another point of
playing e6 is the knight comes to e7 to
support the other knight so again
if white ever captures on c6 knight
recaptures and you don't have doubled
pawns
pawn to d3 just reinforcing e4
now pawn to a6 kicking the bishop and
here in this line where black has not
put the bishop on g7
or played d5 you can actually get away
with saving the bishop
so bishop a4 has been played here a lot
of the times you'll see take but i think
after takes after probably just knight
takes
i don't think white is significantly
better here
you can just save the bishop go to a4
knight to g6 and now that the knight has
gone to g6
it can make some sense to capture on c6
and force the queen to move
you don't get the knight coming to its
natural square on c6 where it can
jump in on d4 in the future
and now after queen retakes you have
pawn to a4
and pawn to b6 just kind of helping out
this c
pawn here black can try for d5 they're
going to go like bishop e7 or bishop d6
castle short but this position is also
pretty equal like i said i can't really
find a great line that
punishes queen b6 it's just that it's a
little bit slow
for black because they make a lot of
queen moves
but that is the queen b6 line he said i
figured i should just mention it because
it's popped up recently
the other this minor line that we're
going to cover here
is knight to f6 this is like the third
most popular move
after g6 and e6 so this also deserves
attention
and here white should go knight to c3
reinforcing
e4 also supporting the bishop in case of
any future
queen to b6 moves and
here black can play it looks like one
of two moves unless i'm getting my notes
mixed up again
they can try and go g6
g6 has been played before the game i
have referenced here is from 1996
where white can go e5 and hit the knight
right away
your knight goes to g4 you're
threatening to take on e5 so bishop
takes c6
is almost forced and now d takes
c6 i should note black doesn't want to
take with the b
b pawn here contrary to what scholastic
players might know
capture towards the center you want to
capture towards the outside
to open up a path for your bishop open
up paths for your queen
not d5 specifically because of the
knight
but you want to make sure that you're
helping the development of your pieces
instead of hurting it
if you go with the b-pawn if you go
bishop to a6 in the future d3 might hurt
this bishop
because it's supported by the pawn on c2
and a6
may not look like a great diagonal the
a6 to f1 diagonal
probably not going to be the best for
black so you capture towards the outside
with your d-pawn
and kick the knight away knight goes to
h6
knight to e4 and uh is getting ready to
jump in on d6 or f6 if black isn't
careful
pawn to b6 supporting the c5 pawn that's
under attack
queen to e2 knight f5 pawn to c3 bishop
g7 and g4
hitting the knight hopefully these moves
don't need too much understanding
there's kind of filler moves but
here white does have a little bit of an
advantage here
the knight is forced to go to h6 and
white can expand in the center with d4
so g6 is one possible move but i think
white does get
to expand in the center pretty early
one move that might look good
but is a little dubious is knight to d4
this is a move that is found in some
variations of the
actually the bird variation of the rui
lopez where the knight goes to d4
looking to trade off minor pieces and
if you're playing white don't get
tempted and trade off the knights right
away
because your knight on c3 is going to be
hit and it doesn't seem like there's a
great place to put it
you can try going to d5 but you hang
your your e4 pawn
so don't don't take on d4 here it's okay
to give up your bishop
after all one of the main ideas is to
trade the bishop for the knight in the
first place and here black is just
spending time to have you do it anyway
so you can go with a move like pawn to
e5 and now after
captures captures knight to d5
you have a strong move here knight to g5
kind of ignoring some opening principles
you're moving pieces more than once out
of the opening
but here is a bit tricky to find the
correct move
for black if you try something like um
if you try f6 trying to kick the knight
away you're still going to be fine
whites can uh
oops white can castle
um or knight e4 i think 94 is the move i
have
pawn to f5 pawn to c4
offering a trade of knights and knight
to c7 this is going to be a move we see
repeated in the future
instead of the knight jumping forward
it's going to go back to c7
and then knight takes c5 here
white has a little bit of an advantage
after the knights trade d6
86 ed6 knight a4 hopping to the edge
where it's supported by the queen
you don't really want to go to d3 and
block your d-pawn that's going to trap
your bishop forever
okay not forever but for a few moves
queen e7 queenie ii
takes takes bishop e7 and white has a
bit of a better
end game uh d4 is going to come to open
up the bishop
unite is already he's not great but he's
already out he's off the back row
but white should have a little bit of an
advantage here
okay so if f6 if white gets a better end
game
what if we try pawn to f5 this is a move
that
has been recommended in some books where
white can castle
pawn to a6 and move the knight to c3
and the idea is that you're going to
trade off the knights here
but i'm not really sure about this white
does get
to open up their their center for their
bishop to develop
and it's a little difficult to find out
where the best square for this dark
square bishop in the future
is going to be now for the rest of this
example black's not going to play the
best moves
um but it's like this position here is
already still good for white but um
some idea could be queen to b6 this has
been tried before
and i wanted to demonstrate that here
you have the move
pawn to e6 where you're giving up this
pawn this is an idea that we've seen
alpha zero play against stockfish where
they just push the pawns up
for positional compensation and the idea
behind this
is that if the pawn takes this dark
square bishop is going to
struggle in the long term the only way
to really develop it is going to be
playing pawn to g6 and bishop to g7
and even this diagonal isn't great
because white had made that capture on
c3
and now there's the two pawns staring at
the bishop
so bishop f4 just making sure the center
pawns can't expand and black can't get
the bishop to e7
pawn to g6 bishop to e5 now preventing
bishop to g7 and rook to g8
and white is already doing great here
after knight takes h7 you're already
winning a pawn
so f5 can be very dangerous for black
like i said queen b6 is not the best
move but even before queen b6 the
position is still favorable towards
white
if you're not going to move your f pawn
at all
then h6 is going to be another try but
h6 is probably worse than either of the
f pawn
moves because of a knight f7 sacrifice
if knight takes f7 you have to take the
knight
if you try something like queen b6
trying to save your queen
then you're giving up this rook on h8 so
you have to take it otherwise you're
losing material and now
queen to f3 looks very dangerous you're
hitting the knight you're hitting the
king
the only move is knight to f6 you're
saving
saving your knight the pawn is going to
take it but
if you're going to lose it anyway you
might as well get a pawn out of it
and now e takes or g takes is fine
but i've decided to choose e takes for
our examples tonight
queen to d5 check and the critical move
here for black
is to make sure that you go king to g6
if you put the king on the e file it's
going to be met
by white castling and rookie 1 is
unstoppable
so king to g6 is the only safe move for
black
white castles anyway again trying to get
this rook into the game
queen to b6 hitting the knight and
instead of just moving the knight to c3
that can be a little passive
because then uh black can continue with
development
you go queen d3 check hitting the queen
and saving the knight
and here the king has to go to f7
the only other try is pawn to f5
which there's no immediate punishment
but white is still going to enjoy good
development after rookie one
so king to f7 king is still safe here
pawn to b3 you're looking to get the
bishop developed
queen to c6 pawn to c4
pawn to b6 knight 2 c3
so you get this pawn up to c4 before you
move the knight back
bishop b7 and now you have to be careful
because there is a mate threat
queen takes g2 is checkmate you can't
allow it so you have to go knight d5
blocking it
and here rookie 8 and black
is still holding on but there are you
know series of critical moves they need
to find
that way they don't get checkmated very
early on
in the chat sandra shock is asking is it
advisable to take alpha zero's
principles in practice or is it just too
dangerous to go for positional
compensation
and uh as an amateur player
as far as amateurs using it i mean uh
i'm gonna define amateur as about 1500
probably not
because odds are you're going to hang a
piece later
and if you're down a pawn and then go
down a piece later there's no coming
back
if your you know master level uh
is something to take a look at be
familiar with i mean we see the top gm's
training with alpha zero specifically
magnus to
uh learn these principles so i think
it's something you should familiarize
yourself with
but i wouldn't be too liberal with using
the idea
so good question okay so that was
the knight d4 line here for
four black like i said probably not the
best line
not the best try so what black
should probably do here is uh you know
we looked at g6 we looked at knight to
d4
but queen c7 is another serious try and
a little bit more
theory to this move than the others
white should continue with normal
development by castling
and now if black tries knight to d4
this kinda works now because the queen
is a little bit more active
but you can still go rook to e1 and the
idea is if they take on b5 you take with
the knight and you're hitting the queen
so you're going to get a little tempo
off of that
so black isn't advised to take the
bishop
they should play a6 and hit the bishop
right away
and now an idea to be familiar with is
dropping the bishop back again
if black hasn't made any serious
commitments to their pawn structure it's
still a little flexible
just drop the bishop back try and save
it because it's not a guarantee
where the weaknesses in black's position
are going to be
okay so after bishop to f1 black has
two tries here we'll start with um
an interesting try of pawn to e5 just
clamping down the center white can't
expand
black never needs to worry about white
playing pawn to e5
and here white can go knight to d5
looking for a trade of pieces knight
takes pawn takes now black needs to be
careful about this
uh half open file white does have a lot
of pressure on it
so bishop to d6 protecting
you can try pawn to d6 but i feel like
black is falling
a little bit too far behind in
development here the idea
with protecting with the bishop is that
way you also open yourself
up to castle on the very next move
we can see knight takes e5 and this
works tactically
because if bishop takes e5 it is met
with pawn to f4
so they can't take the knight right away
they have to castle
and now after castling white should play
pawn to f4
protecting this knight and they're going
to enjoy what looks to be an extra pawn
but black is starting to get some peace
activity
and really make a fight in the center
pawn to f6 hitting the knight
knight goes to d3 making sure it
protects f4
and now pawn to b5 expanding on the
queen side a little bit you might see
some bishop b7 action
hitting the d5 pawn and now you'll see
pawn to b3 this is another idea we will
see in some of these more flexible
systems from black
where white will go pawn to b3 and go
bishop to b2
we see pawn to c4 and a trade
and now the knight goes to f2 and
here uh black can try they can try
bishop
takes f4 but it's a little inaccurate
here after bishop takes f4
white does get a tempo on this knight
they can go
pawn to g3 bishop to g5 and c3
and the knight is hit knight has to has
to move and now queen g4 hitting the
knight again
and knight goes to d6 white gets quite a
bit of an advantage here because uh
when black was generating that activity
white was a little behind in development
but because this
knight is loose and they let white get
this you know half move to
to slip in c3 white is
caught up in the development has some
pressure has some threats
again it's really hard to see where this
light square bishop is going to go
and white does have a significant
advantage here of plus two
so instead of taking on f4 right away
black
should be cautious of white catching up
in development it should just go knight
f5 right away
and if white tries something like g3
trying to hold on they can just continue
with bishop b7
and now instead of focusing on f4 focus
on d5
so there is an e5 try from black here
if after you know queen c7 and then
knight d4 and a6 the bishop ends up on
f1 the other try that black has
is knight to g4 with the immediate
threats of taking on f3
and then once you recapture checkmate
so there's a threat here you have to
take care of the threat we will see
pawn to g3 now we'll see knight f3
queen f3 and knight e5 hitting the queen
queen to e2 and pawn to e6 trying to
maybe get in d5
maybe just open up a space for the
bishop
so pawn to b3 we'll see this bishop to
b2 idea
yet again pawn to d6
not going for d5 right away a problem
with d5 is just that white takes and you
can't take back because you have two
attackers
on e5 and this would lose a piece so you
can't go d5 right away
that's why you see d6 from black and now
bishop to b2 just
furthering that plan of developing
bishop to e7
bishop to g2 knight c6 you're getting
this
knight out of the way that way d5 may
become a possibility in the future
also maybe looking to jump in to d4 and
hit the queen again
knight to d1 knight to d4 queen to d3
castles now we see pawn to c3 hitting
this knight again
knight to c6 queen e2 and the idea of
queen e2 is that after black tries some
move
they can break with d4 and get some
space
and i think white is doing okay here i
again i don't think this is significant
uh
advantage for white but it's definitely
very comfortable with this extra space
so this is one
one idea here okay
so let's back up let's see that was
queen c7
and that should cover most of these
knight f6 lines you just go
knight to c3 and you'll get some pretty
standard development
nothing too wild i think the the wildest
line was the one we just looked at where
the queen ends up going to like e2 and
d3 and then back to e2
but okay those are our kind of side
lines not the main moves here
and here black does have other options
i should probably also mention d6 here
before we
move on and i don't believe i covered
knight d4 right away
actually i think i did so let's go look
at d6
pawn to d6 is another move but this is
more of a transposition rather than its
own
line this is going to transpose to some
of those lines in the moscow
white should castle and then the reason
it transposes to the moscow is
bishop to d7 here just breaking the pin
but you'll see white just make normal
moves you have rook to e1
if black tries to kick this bishop right
away it's a little bit inaccurate you
can take on c6 and play d4
and you're already breaking in the
center takes takes
knight f6 and now normally a sicilian
player who plays
the open sicilian would try something
like knight to c3 this is a completely
fine move
but i'm going to recommend the move
bishop to g5 what is the point of this
well they can go e6 and then try and go
bishop e7 and break the pin
uh i should note you can't really take
on e4
if you take on e4 knight takes c6 hits
the queen so you have to take the knight
and then you win the knight in the
center if you take on e4 with the bishop
you take on f6 with your own bishop
there's no good square for
black's bishop to go to so they take on
g2
and now after king takes g2 and pawn
takes f6
white is up a piece here as well so
that's why i recommend you
bishop to g5 is just there's a few more
tricks
which is why black should play pawn to
e6
and now after knight takes c6 bc6 it's
hard to see
why a6 helps black's position in the
long run
and now you might see queen to f3 and
the idea is you're looking to possibly
capture on f6 twice
and here if black plays again a little
inaccurately
is pawn to e5 trying to stop any e5
ideas from white themselves
you just take on f6 and here
in this specific position instead of
taking on f6 and doubling the pawns
you have queen to c3 where you are
hitting the c6 pawn
and now black has to play something like
rick c8 and it's hard to
to see what the purpose of the rook is
here other than purely defending the
pawn
and black's play will be a little
passive and white has a significant
advantage here
so black shouldn't just try and kick the
bishop
away right away those exchanges and
opening the center
does help white a little bit and does
give them a lot of tricks to work with
if you're trying to avoid the tricks you
should try knight to f6 instead
more solid pawn to c3
and we'll see kind of what the pawn
advance is in the italian and the rui
lopez
of pawn to c3 and pawn to d4
now black can hit the bishop
and the bishop goes to f1
so if you know again if black has not
committed their bishop
to g7 if they haven't committed their
center
you just drop back to f1 and now you
might see bishop to g4
with this pin it's not too big of a deal
right now
you can go pawn to d4 and expand in the
center anyway
and trade in the center
now if they capture on f3 you need to
make sure you capture with the pawn
it looks scary because your king is
exposed but you always have king h1 and
moving the bishop in the future
and you can put the rook on g1 and try
and utilize that file for yourself
or if there's any immediate danger your
bishop is able to block on g2
and patch up that hole but the reason
you cannot take with the queen
is because knight takes d4 and you're
losing a center pawn
and this can be pretty rough uh just
losing a pawn like this
so if they do take make sure you capture
with the pawn you're going to be
all right there's no quick attacks black
has the queen
isn't out the other bishop is in doubt
to try and attack your king
so it's no big problem yet pawn to d5 is
a tribe by black
they can try pawn to e5 instead and if
they try pawn to e5 you just lock up the
center
the knight can apply more pressure to f3
so
this may scare some people but bishop to
e3 and after knight takes the pawn takes
and again
this is not the worst position in the
world for whites they always have
king to h1 moving the bishop and then
getting the other rook to g1
and i believe this position was reached
in a world championship game i wish i
could remember the names
i guess i forgot that citation tonight
but this position
is okay it's a little unclear who's
going to
to be better overall but this position
is still playable for both sides
um but like i said they can try and go
d5 and
white should just lock up the center no
need to make trades you can always just
push and take the space space is good
knight to d7 and now you play h3 hitting
the bishop
if the bishop goes to h5 you're already
running into some trouble after g4
and after bishop to g6 uh white just has
some good good space here again we have
this e6 idea
and here fe6 and now the rook can take
as an idea or just simply
develop the rest of your pieces
okay so bishop can take on f3
because retreating can lead to
complications after e6
after bishop takes f3 queen takes f3
here
it's a logical recapture and after
knight takes d4
you have to move queen to d1 so it looks
like you're hanging this pawn but after
queen to d1 you're hitting the knight
and behind it is another pawn
so it's not the end of the world knight
to c6
and here you can you can take on d5 this
was fine it leads to an equal position
but i'm going to recommend e6 here again
because after fe 6
you have just normal development and
taking with the rook on e6 later as an
idea
and it can really make black suffer
particularly with developing the dark
squared bishop
so if black delays too long with
developing their pawns for their bishop
this e6 idea seems to be one that works
and here a little exchange
sacrifice there really isn't you know if
you go back to e1
then black plays pawn to e6 and now
all their pieces are going to develop
their rook is going to get to the center
their king is going to go back to g8
after the rook moves so they're castling
by hand
and here black is really catching up
starting to get some activity so
uh one line that we're going to look at
is rook takes f6
ef6 important to open up the diagonal
for the bishop
and now knight d5 getting the center
pawn
uh pawn to b5 is an idea here uh
and in response is bishop to d3 and the
idea
is even though this knight looks like
it's hanging you have this move bishop
to g6
and then we just say we love tactics
because now the king has to take or if
the pawn takes
the queen is hanging so always tricks in
these positions
so bishop c5 instead putting pressure on
f2
and this position is a little bit better
for whites they can go bishop f4
and continue with natural development
this rook is going to come to c1
and try and get the minor pieces
why would you open his bishop with tempo
with an exchange sacrifice because
you're getting the center pawn
if you don't you are not going to be
winning this center pawn so the idea
is um you're giving up this exchange and
even though it's opening up the bishop
you are getting this center pawn and
you're going to have easy development
yourself
so that would be why and white has a
little bit of an advantage because of
initiative
because white is the one that has
committed to the first capture and black
recaptures white now gets a free move
they're going to take the pawn and now
after like b5
the reason why pawn to b5 is if you try
something like rook to c8
queen to b3 is going to be hitting this
backwards pawn
and now if you try b5 this isn't going
to work because
of tactics discoveries and now king g6
is the only move in bishop d3 to follow
and you have to sacrifice your queen
otherwise you're getting checkmated
so uh that is why you give up the
exchange because you get a center pawn
and some serious
serious play
okay so that should cover
a lot of these lines here i believe that
was our
d6 move and now we are going to get into
some more theory we're going to cover
let's cover the g6 lines and we'll
probably have to cover the e6 lines
next week because i don't think we're
going to have time for them
but this will be good we still get a
look at the main line russell limo
the reason i'm going to do e6 separately
is there's a bit more theory and it's a
bit unique
compared to all the other lines but now
we start getting into the real rasa lima
i want to make sure we covered all those
side lines
to make sure that we don't we don't miss
anything and you have an idea of what to
do
even if your opponent plays suspicious
looking moves
so pawn to g6 and this is the mainline
russell limo
and white has two options to play here
they can either castle or they can take
on c6
we are going to look at takes on c6
first because
it's not played as much
and here if black plays g6
taking on c6 is even more attractive and
the reason why
is black is loosening their pawn
structure a little bit with pawn to g6
you start to see some holes appear on
the dark squares
and then also black is going to have to
spend some time maneuvering the bishop
to g7 while the knight remains on g8
and if white can play d4 fast enough
then black may just have holes that are
too serious
that can be taken advantage of
but with careful play white should
maintain equality or sorry black should
maintain equality
so here we see the d pawn take and this
is for the same reasons that the d-pawn
took and some of the lines we looked at
earlier
is because when you take with the d-pawn
it helps your light square bishop
develop again if you take with the
b-pawn
your light square bishop isn't going to
be too particularly happy on a6
after d3 and it would be better playing
d6
anyway so might as well just get the
d-pawn out of the way now save yourself
a little bit of time
now with the queen staring right here at
the d file we're going to play d3 and
just build a solid pawn chain
open up the the diagonal for our bishop
to develop
this knight is going to go to c3 or d2
castle short is good let's take a look
at some more specific moves
bishop to g7 this is the point of g6
and here you can you can castle here
this is fine
but a little more accurate is going to
be pawn to h3 and this is just making
sure black cannot play bishop to g4
this pin can be a little annoying
like if they play i guess whites can try
and play
c3 if they try and play c3 to stunt the
bishop
something like bishop to g4 can be a
little annoying
because let's say if you try and go
knight d2 right away you're already
hanging upon on d3 so it's going to
require a little bit more attention from
white
pawn to h3 and let's say captures on f3
twice
knight to f6 and castles
white is going to have fine development
for sure this bishop can't really go to
e3 because you're going to hang your
d-pawn
currently but this is probably going to
be more of an equal position i don't see
the advantage white gets out of this
i think better is just to play h3
and deny them the chance of going bishop
g4 and getting any sort of play
knight 2f6 getting prepared to castle
and knight 2 c3 this knight may end up
going to e2 and g3 in the future
it could just be there to help support
the e4 point
but we see black castle here bishop to
e3
and this is hitting the pawn on c5 so
that is why we're going to see black
play pawn to b6
and here white just continues queen to
d2 with natural development
and black goes pawn to e5 now
some of you guys who are in the chat may
notice that the pawn on e5
looks like it's hanging so i'm going to
give you guys a quick second here to see
what
a problem may be with taking this pawn
why would black be okay with giving away
a pawn and
maybe more importantly a center pawn
because of knight takes e4 eternal 1212
coming in with the answer
so if you take on e5 just like
eternal said knight takes e4 and
if you take on e4 bishop takes on e5 and
this is equalization right away
so if you're trying to be a bit more
complicated you take on f7
first you trade off queens and then
here knight to c4 if black is going to
lose this
knight anyway the reason why black moves
it to c4 is that way it forces white
to recapture and loosen their pawns a
little bit and now after rook takes d8
this is again is equal there's not much
here
uh where white is much greater and
if black really wanted to instead of
rook to d8 or sorry not instead of rook
to d8 um
here after rook to d8 white can try
something like castles
uh black can even be tempted by the idea
of bishop c3 and bc3 and white has
tripled pawns and here we actually see
almost the entire c
file filled up by pawns
it's a bit of a funny line here white is
still fine it's not like black can
attack these pawns immediately but it's
it's not something you should be proud
of
but yes uh you can't really take on e5
because of knight to e4
so instead of going for it if your
opponent plays this against you
just play solidly and the move you
should
you should play is bishop to h6 this is
looking to trade off the dark square
bishops
where um this dark sword bishop can be a
great defender
in this fian kettle setup
but um let's see we have another
question in the chat eternal is asking
doesn't the bishop pair favor black as
the 3-2 pawn majority is too close to
the king
um let's see is this back in the
in this line yeah yeah so like black
doesn't need to take on c3
um black should probably just uh let it
sit
and not give up the bishop pair for no
reason but it was just an example
you know at the amateur level taking on
c3 is completely fine and playable
but yeah this this bishop doesn't need
to trade itself off
a good question like i said the move you
should try and play is bishop to h6
trying to trade off the dark square
bishops and
black now goes queen to d6 they do not
need to take on h6 and invite white's
queen down to party with the black
king instead you go queen to d6 and the
idea is that you are protecting the e5
pawn because after some of these trades
this e5 pawn may actually be hanging and
it's best just to
defend it be solid and further your
development because now after the light
square bishop develops your rooks are
connected
and you're good to put those on open
files we see takes on g7 twice
and now castles and rook to e8
again supporting the pawn on e5 and now
we will see
white they don't really have much
progress to make on the king side so
we'll see them expand on the queen side
and try and take space over there
where after pawn to a5 stopping this
a4 pawn we get pawn to b3 just creating
another chain keeping it solid knight to
h5 coming in
to f4 and now knight to e2 that way if
the knight comes to f4 we just trade it
off
and it's not going to be a big deal for
white
and here a move like f6 just
again solidifying e5 you're not really
adding any weaknesses to your position
here
and this is a pretty equal position
so that is um that's kind of what
happens if white
takes on c6 after g6
where um you know black won't really uh
or what what am i saying um i just
forget i said anything we're gonna move
on
um after after um g6 the other option
white has
is just to castle right away and uh they
don't need to take on c6 right away
and like i said both of them are good
moves but castles is played a little bit
more at the top level
and here we will just see bishop to g7
what happens if black tries and kicks
this bishop
well then we do want to trade because
this is the point of playing bishop b5
in the first place you take this knight
to get rid of some of that center
control black has
and if they ever play a6 like this very
early on
just take on c6 because there's there's
really no benefit for black
why is black forcing you to do something
you want to do already there's no
benefit
of playing a6 um
you know after like b takes this doesn't
help
after d takes i i don't see why a6 is
played why couldn't she play something
more active like bishop g7 instead
we have uh jean-michel royer i hope i'm
saying that right
is asking the bishop trade on g7 is it a
good idea for white
and this is back in the lines we just
looked at where
blackfin kettled the bishop and then
white went bishop h6
yes i have to say that's a good idea the
bishop on g7
is a very powerful piece one of the main
defenders of the fianchetto pawn
structure
so once you trade off those dark square
bishops it does create some dark square
weaknesses that hopefully the queen and
the knight
can try and get on and rushing the h
pawn up to hit g6
is also an idea um but examples of that
are going to be best found in probably
the
yugoslav dragon where you see this
fiancato structure so i recommend you to
go see
our yugoslav video that we've done a few
months ago
actually probably a year ago now but it
was a while ago i did that
it gives some better examples of trading
on h
or sorry g7
okay but back to this line uh oh yeah i
was saying why a6 is bad
they should just go bishop g7 it's going
to be more active contribute more to the
overall position more than a6 is ever
going to
and here we do reach another fork where
white has two options they can go pawn
to c3
and this is trying to close off and
strengthen our weak diagonal
where after something like knight 2f6
there's two options here there is rook
to e1 and e5
we'll look at e5 first it's a little bit
more dubious because the knight just
goes to d5
and we start seeing that black has more
pieces developed than white
you're gonna have to go d4 to get space
in the center
try and make up for your lack of
development you have to get this bishop
out somehow
a trade in the center castles knight c3
and again we're going to see this idea
of knight 2 c7
hitting the bishop and here
i do want to mention if knight takes c6
or sorry knight c3
pawn takes c3 and after d6 ed6
queen d6 and a4 it's hard to see what
black has gained out of taking on c6
i think it's better to maintain some
tension keep some pieces
on the board and threaten this bishop on
b5
and we just let it sit there rook to e1
knight takes b5 knight takes b5 d6 these
moves are all pretty forced because
they're captures
take on d6 take on d6 with pawn now
you can't take with the queen because
the knight on b5 is protecting
and black is going to end up with this
isolated queen's pawn that may or may
not turn out to be a weakness
but this is going to be one of the
things that is in the fight for the game
we'll see the knight go to e5 and this
is kind of your starting position
if black tries and plays or sorry if
white tries to play e5
the other idea here like i said after c3
and knight f6
the other idea is rook to e1 and this is
just protecting the pawn this is
probably
probably more straightforward for
beginners i have another question
in chat from eterna1212 will the e6
variation be covered today with black
intending on playing 97 and a6
we will not have the time to cover those
lines today but i do plan on covering
them next week so if you're interested
in e6 variation which is a bit more
unique
has probably more theory than the g6
lines
um but like i said that that's what
we're going to be covering
next week but back to the
back to the g6 line um the other idea
after
uh c3 and i6 is rookie one like i said
probably more straightforward directly
protecting the pawn
black castles and now we see white go h3
this is to get around any d6 and bishop
g4 ideas
stopping the knight from coming in
and now pawn to e5 so you'll see black
play pawn to e5 quite a bit
trying to stop white from pushing their
own pawn
avoid getting that tempo on the night
um but here after e5 white still has
enough uh protectors on d4 to play pawn
to d4 anyway
we see a lot of captures and i should
mention you know that this knight on c6
captures
first because if you capture with the
pawn there is the idea of bishop takes
on c6 and
this may black may not like this idea
it should be fine for them but
this is one of the reasons why taking
with the other knight first you also get
this tempo on the bishop which
encourages white to trade knights as
well
e takes queen takes and d5
e5 is here knight to e4
and now knight to c3 we see a trade on
c3
and after queen c7 this position is
pretty equal
as well and this will be your starting
position after
c3 knight f6 and rookie 1.
instead of going c3 um the main move
here after bishop to g7
is rook to e1 again just directly
protecting the pawn
and here black has two tries
there's a lot of forks very early on and
it seems like on every
move here but we'll look at e5 here
e5 is the common idea so what happens if
black tries to play it a little early
there's two tries by white here but i'm
gonna go over what i think is the better
try
is bishop takes c6 dc6
and now pawn to d3 queen e7 knight to d2
some standard developing moves now in
the other lines we looked at this knight
went to c3 i should clarify
why it's going to d2 in this line it's
actually on its way to
c4 where it's going to help put pressure
on e5
and it's going to be very hard for black
to just kick it away
uh i guess they can try and go be b5 but
knight e3
is a pretty good central square for that
knight
so we see knight to f6 just normal
development getting prepared to castle
knight to c4 putting the pressure knight
to d7
and this is adding yet another defender
to the pawn
bishop to d2 castles and here
a3 b6 is equal maybe white has
a little bit of an advantage because
bishop c3 is coming
and e5 is the targets but i don't think
it's
anything to write home about
but this is probably going to be white's
tri if black goes e5 early
otherwise black should just go knight f6
again continue developing their pieces
looking for activity
okay i need to make sure i am getting
the correct
lines here now white goes c3 here
this is definitely a try here
they can try going knight to c3 they go
knight to c3 you're just going to see
more of the standard moves from both
sides you're going to see white
hit with e5 forcing this knight back to
e8 and then they're just going to
continue with knight you know knight c3
h3
pawn to d3 and we see this knight e4
maneuver again
but um that is uh
a try with knight to c3
i also want to make sure i cover e5 this
is probably white's most aggressive
try against the russolima this main line
here
the knight goes to d5 we've seen this
idea before
knight to c3 knight to c7 we should be
familiar with these ideas now
and here if knight takes and the other
line i believe it was the b pawn that
took but here the d-pawn takes is just
going to be killer
because this bishop is not going to have
much hope on this
a1 to h8 diagonal
so you see knight to c7 hitting the
bishop
and here you can take on c6 take on c6
and knight e4 and here there's some very
strong attacking chances
for this knight on e4 even
like temporarily sacrificing it on f6
if you know black makes a nothing move
knight to f6
check is actually a good candidate move
because after
uh like pawn takes then pawn takes comes
with
check you see king f8 and you win this
bishop on g7
and white has a bit of a plus here
because of all the time that took for
the king to move
he should be fine here b3 and bishop b2
is going to come
and black is going to have to react to
this
so this is probably the most aggressive
try
so instead of allowing knight to f6 as
an option
we see knight to e6 closing off the file
pawn to d3 castles bishop e3 more of
these standard moves
b6 to protect the attacked pawn
queen d2 just connecting the rooks
knight to d4 and we see a trade of
knights and this bishop to h6 idea again
and here pawn to c5 just to kind of
solidify
and here white just has a little tiny
advantage
again you're not going to see all the
attacking chances and big
big chances white has compared to the
open sicilian but if you're looking for
something solid
the rosso limo is going to be it
now instead of e5 we'll finish up here
with the main line c3
and after c3 we see black castle
pawn to h3 and there's two moves here
for black
we'll start with queen to b6 which is a
little inaccurate but
is actually pretty cool because we see
something that
almost resembles a king's indian defense
i'm not going to explain these moves too
much because we are running out of time
but i want to show it off
is that when you save the bishop you see
a few
pawn moves the bishop comes back to
b3 just kind of eyeing this f7 square
inviting the knight to come to a5 and
you move the bishop again you lose the
tempo
but it's not like black has anything
crazy they can try right away
you'll see both sides develop their
pieces
and then after black
expands here on the queen side you'll
see white expand in the center
and the reason this reminds me a lot of
the king's indian
is especially black's setup here where
you will eventually see
knight to e8 and an f5
tri so you might see like knight two h2
and
f5 f3 and then if you see f4 bishop f2
these are not the best moves white does
have a good plus here
but this is just an example you can you
can try and get transpositions to the
king's indian
i believe this is going to be a bit
better for white than the normal kings
indian
but these transpositions do exist where
the plans radically change
but instead of queen b6 where it's a
little a little dubious just because
just because that position may lead to
better better one for white
the better try is pawn to e5
and black sorry white should not go for
this capture on c6
trying to win the center pawn uh there
are going to be some issues
after rook to e8 and now after knight to
f3
your e pawn is hanging so again
don't be too tempted to take this pawn
on e5 in most of these lines
it can be poison so if you are going to
try and go for it just
double check your calculations make sure
black doesn't have any resource to
either pick up a pawn
or or get some serious counter play so
instead of e5 just
go with d4 focus on breaking in the
center developing your pieces
we'll see c take c takes we'll see the
knight take again
after knight takes e takes queen takes
we get
our position from earlier and this
transposes is the main line one of our
sidelines transposes into this main line
where here we see pawn to e5 the knight
to e4
knight to c3 we see a trade and queen to
c7 like i said this is going to be kind
of your
starting position a good starter move
would be bishop to a3 hitting the rook
rook to d8 bishop to d3 just bringing it
back
trying to regroup your pieces bishop to
e6
rook a to c1 rook a to c8 and
this is going to be your main starting
position
of the main line so i want to thank
everyone for stopping in tonight
definitely a lot of theory this has been
the the most theory-heavy opening to
explain lecture that that i've
given recently next week we are going to
cover the e6 lines in the russell limo
so
watch out for part two coming next week
we're going to move over to twitch where
we're starting a new lecture
winners circle where we're going to be
going through the games of winners of
important tournaments in history
but this was chess openness explained
i'm nick risco i will see you
next time
you